a trump supporter is shot to death in
portland while the media and democrats
blame
trump wisconsin officials beg president
trump not to visit and members of the
left continue to defend looting and
rioting i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben well every weekend i beg you please
stop burning down the country and no one
apparently takes me up on it
and frankly i'm getting a little
irritated with the situation it feels
like probably you should take me up on
it i mean like what's so difficult about
this
stop burning down the country of course
i'm mostly addressing myself at this
point
to very specific groups of people we
talk about people who are burning down
the country
i am not talking about all the people
that the media are talking about because
the people
the media are talking about are not the
ones who are actually burning down the
country right now
the people who are burning down the
country in portland the people who are
doing it in seattle the people who have
been doing it
in places like chicago and washington dc
and los angeles and new york
in kenosha those people are not white
nationalists
they are not okay white nationalists are
evil they are terrible
they are the worst people on planet
earth they are awful
i have been their chief target many many
times so believe you me when i say that
these are the worst people on earth
i mean it okay literally i've had white
nationalists arrested by the fbi for
targeting me and my family
so this is not about the white
nationalists this is about the fact that
for months on end
the media have been soft pedaling and
pretending that antifa
and black lives matter writers and
looters doesn't mean everybody who's
gone to a blm protest is a rioter or a
looter but there are many members of blm
who are in fact rioters and looters
have been let off the hook by the media
for the vast amounts of violence they've
been doing in american cities and this
has been going on for months on end
if there are a tea party rally that once
broke out into violence the way the blm
marches seem to continue to do regularly
if there were a right-wing agitating
group that glommed on
to any sort of conservative protest and
then went into violence against the
police officers
the media would immediately lump
everybody together and they would say
that this is the outgrowth of a
right-wing movement but as soon as it is
left-wing or a cause the media agrees
with
then suddenly it disappears it just does
it's not happening at all
is it like it really isn't apparently
it's all a figment
of your imagination now you may be
watching the goings on across the
country and you may be thinking to
yourself wait a second
hasn't this stuff been going on for a
while like haven't we seen riots in la
like the first week
of the black lives matter protests
didn't we see
riots in los angeles in which they had
to curfew the entire county of los
angeles at 7 pm every night like for a
week
yes that did happen it's not a figment
of your imagination didn't they have to
do some similar stuff in new york and
washington dc didn't we see people
running roughshod through these cities
haven't we seen portland burning for
months on end didn't we see
an entire fake republic set up in
seattle with the
quasi approval of the city government
and then two people got shot there and
died there
didn't we haven't we seen in in essence
about three dozen people who have died
connected with
these various riots and looting sprees
haven't we seen that haven't we seen an
enormous number of injury
billions in property damage haven't we
seen all that well according to the
media none of it happened it's all
trump's fault
so really the only thing that's
happening here is that president trump
is a very bad man
and the only reason that people become
violent if there's a cause they
that the media love the only reason
people become violent is because trump
is agitating them or the right is
agitating them
or it's white nationalist outsiders who
are agitating them or something like
that the problem is
that is a square peg in a round hole
there are times
when the people to blame are white
nationalists in fact the vast majority
of
violent attacks in the united states for
the first six months of the of 2020
were in fact white nationalist attacks
okay but then it turns out that when it
came to the burning of american cities
which began
in may and june it turns out that that
is not the white nationalist and it's
sort of important to determine who is
doing what kind of violence
because if you actually want to call
people out you have to call people out
for the specific things that they do
as we'll see this is an extraordinarily
important point
because right now what the media are
trying to do is retcon this whole thing
what they're trying to do
is basically what the democratic party
did with ilhan omar so ilhan omar is a
radical anti-semitic member of the
democratic party caucus
she's well-respected anti-semitic member
because she appears on the cover of
rolling stone with nancy pelosi
and she does tours with nancy pelosi and
nancy pelosi endorses her
for re-election despite the fact that
she openly hates jews okay ilhan omar
was originally going to be condemned
she was going to be censured by the
house and democrats because they didn't
want to fracture their coalition and
they were afraid of henomar in the squad
they decided to water it down and
instead condem
bad language of any sort all across the
board
now i'm old enough to remember when
donald trump did something similar with
charlottesville do you remember this
had to set up the predicate for what
we're about to talk about here it's
important to remember what exactly
happened with regards to what president
trump said at charlottesville and why
people got so mad originally
so remember there was this white
nationalist march in charlottesville
and it broke into violence because they
started
having clashes with antifa members and
then a member of the white nationalists
drove a car into a group of anti-white
nationalist protesters in
charlottesville
and the president spoke that day and he
specifically did not
call out the alt-right or the white
nationalists right in the in the first
iteration he didn't call them out so
much
right in the first iteration he sort of
said there was violence on many sides on
many sides
of the first iteration there were
several different iterations of what the
president said here
and he condemned the white nationalists
he didn't condemn white nationalists
over the weekend and then he suggested
i'm not talking about the good when i
say they're good people i don't i'm not
talking about the white nationalists or
anything like that
i'm specifically talking about something
different
i'm talking about people who are
marching and it turns out that the
people who are marching
in some cases were there were no good
people who were marching that night okay
bottom line is this
the specific comments that president
trump
made that got him in all sorts of hot
water was
he suggested many people many people
right this is the direct quote from
trump on charlottesville this is the
original one that got him in real
trouble
friday night right he said quote we
condemn in the strongest possible terms
this egregious display of hatred
bigotry and violence on many sides on
many sides
and everybody wait when will hold up on
many sides there's a white nationalist
march
in charlottesville and then it broke
into violence and a member of that group
ended up killing somebody on saturday
morning and you're saying on many sides
like why can't just name the bad guys go
back i did an entire
rageful podcast on this that the
president had a specific duty to call
out to people who are
actually responsible for the violence
that he had a specific duty
yes he could call out antifa for being
violent because they were in fact
violent and are in fact violent they've
been violent for years
but the people who were the specific
instigators in charlottesville were the
alt-right and the white nationalists and
he had a specific duty not to create a
moral equivalency there
but he got all sorts of flack for this
well now the media are attempting to do
exactly what they condemned president
trump for in charlottesville it's truly
amazing
i mean it really is amazing they are so
unbelievably dishonest because
if you assume that that was a matter of
principle for members of the media and
the democratic party
that they just didn't like that
president trump wasn't calling out
specifically the bad guys
right and that he wasn't that he was
drawing a moral equivalence or he's
being deliberately vague in order to
provide cover
today the entire democratic party and
the media infrastructure are attempting
to conflate
what is happening in america's major
cities and pretend that everybody is
equally responsible for what's happening
in america's major cities
that when we are watching chicago loops
the chicago loop looted
when we were watching melrose avenue
burn when we are watching
kenosha burn when we are watching
washington dc get looted
when we were watching an increase in
massive levels of crime in new york city
due to the fun the police movement when
we were watching all this stuff
that's just kind of everybody's
responsibility it's sort of out there in
the wind and the reason the media are
doing this is because if they
acknowledge
that this is a left-wing movement that
is burning america's major cities and
that for months
they did nothing about it for months in
fact they poo-pooed it and said it
wasn't happening and told you that
writing and looting were a figment of
your imagination these were all just
peaceful protesters and then when
president trump talked about using
federal force in order to quell the
protesters
or when tom to call the rioters and the
looters not the protesters and when tom
cotton the senator from arkansas
talked about using the insurrection act
to quell rioting and looting
that really they were cracking down on
protesters and the media kept conflating
the two
for purposes of suggesting that these
were all non-violent wonderful people it
was all a figment of your imagination
and then it turns out the american
people are not in fact as stupid as
advertised and have eyeballs in their
heads and prefrontal cortexes at the
front of their brains
that the media flipped on this
immediately and now it became
everybody's issue now it's trump's fault
now it's white nationalists right for
for literally months at this point the
city's been burning
and it's all the white nationalists
weird isn't it
weird or at least if it's not all the
white nationalists at least they're
equally responsible aren't they
now this is just not true it's just not
factually accurate
in the same way that it was not
factually accurate for the presidents of
the united states and charlottesville
to claim equal responsibility between
the white supremacists and white
nationalists and the antifa members it
is not
it is not even it's significantly less
accurate actually for the media to
suggest that what's been going on in
america's major cities
is generally the result of either trump
or the white nationalists
that's in fact that's insane that's
totally crazy
okay but the media are pushing that
agenda because again the real agenda is
not about the white nationalists or
trump it's about downplaying the
responsibility of democrats and the
media for tutti
for tutting padding on the head and in
some cases actively encouraging the
violence that's been going on
in america's major cities so that is the
backdrop to what happened
this weekend this stuff has not been
happening in a vacuum the media
have been pushing it many democrats
ranging from ayanna presley to maxine
waters have been pushing this kind of
activity for a very long time here
and people like joe biden have not been
standing up strong and saying
these movements that we largely identify
with need to stop the violence
they have not been naming in shaming
instead they've been deliberately vague
because they are afraid of fracturing
the coalition
president trump got badgered over and
over and over after his original many
sides statements at charlottesville
and many sides on many sides he got
badgered over and over will you condemn
the white nationalist will you condemn
the alt-right will you do that
and he was right to be badgered about
that okay you're allowed to badger
people
to condemn bad people will one member of
the mainstream media specifically ask
joe biden to call that antifa by name
will one member of the mainstream media
specifically ask him to call out blm
writers and looters by name the black
lives matter writers and looters by name
will one i don't think so do you i would
be shocked if they do
and if they and if they do and joe biden
does the moral equivalence routine
if joe biden pretends that everybody
bears equal responsibility for this
isn't he providing cover in the same way
that they accuse trump of providing
cover to the alt-right in
charlottesville
remember that was such an egregious
situation according to the media and
according to joe biden
trump's charlottesville comments were
literally the reason he supposedly
launched his 2020 campaign now of course
that was a lie joe biden's run for
president every presidential election
since
1872 but but the fact is that that was
joe biden's stated rationale right he
said
charlottesville those comments were so
egregious so morally bereft so soulless
that i had to jump into the race
okay so then joe biden doesn't that mean
that if you want to restore america's
soul as you suggest you're going to
you need to call out by name the people
who are burning america's major cities
and shooting people shouldn't and by the
and by the way
shouldn't you stop lying about the
people on the other side
because in some cases in many of these
cases they're not white nationalists
when after kyle rittenhouse this this 17
year old
man young man shot three people in
kenosha wisconsin
the media immediately ran with the
narrative many on twitter immediately
ran with the narrative who's white
nationalist i have yet to see one shred
of evidence that kyle written house is
white nationalist
and yet as you will see joe biden is
running with that narrative today
as we will see there was a shooting in
portland over the weekend a pro-trump
man was killed and they're running with
the narrative that the guy was naturally
a white nationalist because he was there
and he was pro-trump okay this is
insanity we'll get some more of this in
just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
with the current heatwave in
los angeles the last thing you want to
be doing is waiting around in the
parking lot in your car waiting for your
car to be out of the shop or
standing in the parking lot in a giant
line waiting for your
car part to be delivered to you you
don't need to be at one of these
autozone type stores in other words and
what you do need is the internet
rockauto.com it's much easier than going
to one of these stores you have to wait
outside in line with the social
distancing and everything
instead you should just go online and
get the part that you need number one
you're gonna save time
number two you're gonna save money
number three you're not gonna be up
charged
based on exactly what the the big parts
shop wants to charge you
also you're not gonna have to wait
because i mean the fact is that they'll
probably order it online anyway and then
they'll upcharge you for the service
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same exact parts rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts the rockauto.com
catalog
is unique remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your car
or truck right now and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available
for your vehicle right shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box and they
will know that we sent you again save
yourself some time and save yourself
some money okay so
this brings us to the actual news okay
so over the weekend
there was a big confrontation portland
of course has been completely overrun by
antifa members and black lives matter
riders and looters in the evenings and
you'll recall that the
trump administration sent in federal
forces
in order to protect federal property and
they were ripped up in town as fascists
by the media by the democrats how dare
they remember
they were just lying they were saying
that that the the feds were sending
unmarked vans to simply arrest people
for no apparent reason and then beat the
hell out of them and all of a sudden
it was not that wasn't true okay they
were literally authorized by federal
laws to protect federal property from
rioters and looters and yes they could
exit federal property in order to go
after perps
okay so in any case the idea was that
and the media ran with the narrative
that the violence in portland was then a
result of the feds being there which of
course was not true because the feds had
only arrived in the last seven minutes
and the riots have been going on for a
running total of three months at this
point and mayor ted wheeler the mayor of
portland has allowed that to go on and
kate brown the governor of oregon has
allowed that to go on because she
refuses to call on the national guard
so the the antifa members and the blm
writers and looters and i keep saying
blm writers and looters because
again i don't think that everybody who
has marched with blm is a writer and a
looter of course that is obviously
untrue there are millions of people who
have marched with blm
i think many of them don't actually
understand the or the agenda of the
black lives matter organization
and many of them have been tricked by
the media into believing that the
generalized narrative of american
systemic racism
is is both true and also allows them to
dissociate from america's evil and make
themselves feel morally superior to the
rest of america but in any case
that distinction is worthwhile but many
of the writers and looters are in fact
blm associated okay that's just a fact
these are not republican voters they're
not white nationalists they're people
who openly wear blm shirts
many of them are okay and antifa is a
real group and so they've been doing
this for months on end okay so over the
weekend
a group called patriot prayer which is a
right-wing group they're not white
nationalists
okay the media calling these folks white
nationalists that is not accurate now
does this mean this is smart
to drive through the center of portland
with the american flags and the
blue lives matter flags and all that
first of all it's a free country you
should be allowed to drive
into civilian areas without having to
worry about this so there's only one
person who's responsible for this that's
mayor ted wheeler and the mayor of
portland is a garbage heap he is a dung
heap of a mayor
he's a terrible terrible mayor i used to
say bill de blasio is the worst mayor in
america he does not hold a candle to ted
wheeler
and this is incredible if you watch your
city on fire for three months
and you actively incentivize this and by
the way antifa has
had a low level has had low level run of
the place for years on that i mean andy
no
the reporter who spent an enormous time
in amounts of time covering
antifa in portland his videos going back
like to 2017
of antifa literally stopping people on
street corners and directing traffic and
stuff it's crazy
so mayor ted wheeler the garbage mayor
he doesn't allow the feds to come in
he tells them to get out in fact he
specifically tells the portland cops
not to clear the streets and so when the
patriot prayer guys show up in their
trucks
there are no cops to stop any of it and
this leads to confrontations
now does that mean that it is smart to
initiate confrontations on the street
it is not smart to to if even if antifa
is running the streets it is the job of
the local authorities to clear them
it is not a good idea to to initiate uh
well i won't say an issue because the
people who initiated are the people who
took over the streets it is not a good
idea
to put yourself in a situation where
violence is likely to occur but patriot
prayer is not in fact a white
nationalist group the founder of the
group
has explicitly denounced white
nationalism on multiple occasions and
white supremacism on multiple occasions
he has called them all sorts of names
which is perfectly appropriate okay the
media have covered this as it was white
nationalists coming to portland that is
not
what the evidence demonstrates because
we'll show you the video and then we'll
tell you what happened
in just one second first let us talk
about something good that you can do
something actually nice and good that
you can do
for your community something you can do
for people in need if you've got a car
that's taking up space sitting in your
driveway that you don't use
that you're paying insurance on i have
one question for you why get rid of it
donate it to cars
for kids many of you have heard their
jingle get ready for it get ready for it
i'm gonna stick it in your head it's
gonna be here the rest of the day until
you donate that used car or truck
two cars for kids ready one eight seven
seven cars for kids
k-a-r-s cars for kids
okay now it's stuck in your head until
you literally do what you're supposed to
do
and take that used car truck that you're
not using anymore just sitting in your
driveway and you donated to cars for
kids
cars for kids makes the process of
donating your car quick and easy
it takes just about two minutes they
handle all the details all the paperwork
all you need to do is schedule a pickup
and sign the title your car donation is
fast and free
it is usually picked up within 24 hours
and often even the same day
and cars for kids will take your car
even if it's not running donating your
car is tax
your tax deduction is based on the sale
price of your car cars for kids works
hard to sell your car for the best price
which means more funds for their charity
and a bigger tax deduction for you so
everybody wins
as a special thank you for donating your
car cars for kids it gives you a
vacation voucher good
for a three-day two-night hotel stay as
well so this is pretty awesome
with cars for kids you get that
professional service convenient pickup
maximum tax deduction a vacation voucher
and a good deed donate today
at carsforkids.org ben remember that's
cars with a k k-a-r-s cars for kids
and that's right it'll be stuck in your
head forever until you do it now they'll
give you a donation experience you
deserve
cars for kids dot org slash band cars
for kids dot org
slash man that's cars with k four the
number four kids
dot org slash event okay so here's what
happens over the weekend
patriot prayer shows up in portland
they're driving their trucks they've got
the trump flags and antifa
because they own the streets and because
the cops have been told to stand down
confrontation occurs so the patriot
prayers
aren't shooting the members of antifa
who are trying to literally block
traffic instead they are amazing them so
here's what the uh here's what some of
the video looked like
over the weekend you can see they are
firing mace from the windows to try and
force the streets open
people getting out of the way uh they
were also firing paintballs at some
of the at some of the antifa members
hey is any of this good of course none
of this is good where the hell are the
cops where the hell are the feds and the
answer is mayor ted wheeler is a garbage
mayor it is his job to make sure
that when you leave i said it last week
this stuff is predictable
when you leave the legitimate government
monopoly on the use of force
at the back door then there will be
something that fills the gap and
typically it tends to be tribal violence
okay that is what you are seeing in the
streets okay then
a pro-trump supporter was murdered
literally just murdered on the street
okay so here is the video it's troubling
obviously
you can't see it particularly well but
that is your warning so you will see a
man in the background
walk up to a walk up to another man and
literally just shoot him point blank
and what you can what you seem to be
able to hear in the background
is we got a trumper here right we have a
trump supporter so that means time to
murder him apparently
here's what that sounded like
[Music]
go
he shoots the man man's dead you just
shot a man to death right there on the
street this antifa member
and now we have uh we have some
knowledge of who this guy is because he
is indeed an antifa member he is not a
white supremacist who committed this
murder
okay according to the new york post an
ex-military man who calls himself 100
antifa 100 antifa and ready for war
is being investigated over the deadly
shooting of a president trump supporter
in portland
according to a report his name is
michael forest rhino 48
he's being investigated over the death
of aaron danielson a supporter of the
right-wing patriot prayer group who was
part of a caravan of trump supporters
who flooded the city saturday
police sources told the oregonian he was
identified in part by a distinctive
tattoo on his neck
of a black power fist hmm seems he had
some politics
as well as a call from his estranged
sister who recognized him in video and
photos of the deadly attack
the 36 year old sister was first alerted
after a threatening call that woke her
up at 8am on sunday morning our whole
family was in danger unless we turned
him over
we reached out to police confirmed we
recognized michael in the screenshots
from the shooting
she told the paper apparently he's
estranged from most of the family
including his parents after stealing
from them
and then she decried the shooting as uh
not par not the solution
to the country's problems he regularly
posts about black lives matter and
protests on his social media
he says i'm 100 antifa all the way i'm
willing to fight for my brothers and
sisters insisting he would not run
from the violence now here's the thing
he was cited at a july 5th protest on
allegations of possessing a loaded gun
in a public place
resisting arrest and interfering with
police he was then given a date to
appear in court later that month
but the allegations were dropped on july
30 with the no complaints according to
court records
no reason was given the multnomah county
district attorney's office said it was
reviewing the case this is
literally a case of a person who
committed a criminal act but was on the
right side
of the leftist narrative being released
without any charges
because the city of portland decides not
to prosecute anymore
people who engage in crime at these
protests so long as they have the right
perspective
and then he went out and murdered
somebody he had a slew of other charges
as well he was also previously charged
with having a loaded glock pistol
for which he didn't have a license and
uh was stopped with his 11 year old
daughter as a passenger in his car the
portland police bureau did not
immediately respond to requests for
comment this is all according to the
new york post okay the response from
members of the crowd when they found out
that this happened were twofold one
misinformation immediately went around
that a trump supporter had shot a black
man because this is
this is what happens now and any story
is immediately filled in
by the internet with black man innocent
black man shot right this just happened
in minneapolis when a
black murder suspect literally killed
himself and committed suicide and
rioting happened anyway
so the false story led to rioters
targeting a gas station
and so there was video of that that was
emerging over the weekend these riders
targeting a gas station in portland you
can see
because that makes perfect sense it's
the gas stations fall that gas station
is systemically racist obviously
so there are the rioters targeting the
gas station
uh always good luck gathering at the
uh at the petrol station preparing for
something or other
okay and then there was a blm activist
who literally told a group of people in
portland
i am not sorry this is direct quote i'm
not sorry an effing fascist
died tonight now is there any evidence
this guy was a fascist the victim in
this case
nope we have no idea whether he was
there is no evidence there's no evidence
he's a white nationalist or white
supremacist
in fact the only thing that we know
about him is that you can see his prone
body lying on the ground and he's
wearing some blue
blue lives matter gear right pro police
gear but that means he's a fascist now
so here is a blm activist don't worry
though
this is not political right i mean this
is white supremacist well as we'll see
everyone bears equal responsibility
according to the media here we go i'm
not angry you're not paying attention
if you're not angry you're not with me
everybody needs to realize what's going
[Music]
on without the police
[Applause]
well i mean there's no evidence the
person's a fascist but if you oppose the
revolution you're a fascist that's the
way communists speak
and then that is if you're if you're not
a bolshevik you're a menshevik right
that's that's the way this works
in just a second we're going to get to
more of this
and the insane media spin that is coming
out of this because this sort of
violence is now occurring
across the nation and these sorts of
encouragements are coming
very clearly from one particular side of
the aisle in extremists
and as we'll see the media are taking
the narrative that it's it's on all
sides on many sides on many sides
remember on many sides was bad until
five seconds ago now on many sides is
very good
that it's a very strong statement
against violence if you say on many
sides we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
right now you might think hey maybe i
need a gun to protect myself i wonder
why you would think such a thing
now maybe as the local police are
removed from my neighborhood
and as people threaten to go into
suburbs and raid property
and harm people maybe you might think
about like it might be a good thing to
have a gun but it's not enough to have a
firearm you have to know
how to use it not only do you have to
know how to use it you have to know when
you have legal protection for it
and not and this is why you need to join
up with the u.s concealed carry
association
you need the proper education
industry-leading training to ensure your
skills are sharp when faced with danger
and you need the nation's best legal
protection should you find yourself god
forbid lost in the aftermath of a
self-defense incident
you need the uscca get started today by
texting gun to 87222
you'll receive the complete concealed
carry and family defense guide for free
we've been doing we've been talking
about uscca for literally years on this
program
it's just it seems a little more
relevant these days in this guide you'll
learn how to detect attackers before
they see you how to survive a mass
shooting seven firearm drills that could
save your life and much much more it's
164 pages comes the bonus
bonus audio version so you can listen
whenever you want
again it's not enough just to own a
firearm you have to know when you can
legally use a firearm how to legally use
a firearm so you can be a responsible
citizen with firearm
in addition if you text it today you'll
be entered to win a thousand bucks to
put toward a gun of your choice that you
can use to protect your family and your
rights text gun
gun to 87 222 right now again text gun
to 87
222 right now the uscca wants to make
sure that you are able to
fully perform your self-defense rights
again self-defense i know that the left
tends to think all self-defense is evil
no self-defense is an inherent right it
pre-exists government
the uscca is trying to effectuate it and
make sure that you follow all legal
procedures in doing so
text gun to 87 222 right now and join up
with the uscca okay so
why was any of this happening in
portland in the first place the reason
this is happening in portland in the
first place is specifically because the
mayor of portland ted wheeler is a
garbage heap
and he's a garbage heap i'm gonna get to
ted wheeler in just a second first i
just need to show you
what's been happening all over the
nation so in washington dc
overnight a blm activist literally told
people
on the streets that he's ready to put
cops in their graves so that's always a
good look here's what that sounded like
i'm at the point where i'm ready to put
these police in the grave
[Music]
i'm at the point where i want to burn
the
white house down
i want to take it to the senators i want
to take it to the congress
i want to take the fight to them and at
the end of the day
if they ain't gonna hear us we burn them
down if they're not gonna hear us we
burn them the f down really well well
done stuff here guys but
but again that guy seems like a white
nationalist to me
and kenosha remember we were told that
kenosha was no big deal as you will see
the media tried to downplay kenosha it
was it was mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful
fiery but mostly peaceful here are just
some pictures from the aftermath of
kenosha you can see entire city blocks
reduced to rubble
again this is a suburb about a hundred
thousand people it is not a major city
you can see stores burn out that good
taste ice cream shop obviously a source
of systemic racism
that uh there's a building completely
completely destroyed
you see entire city blocks basically
raised
don't worry though writing and looting
are okay as we'll see right there's the
uh
the famous the famous car dealership
that was burned to the ground next door
there was a
church that was partially burned
you got the revolution signs on the
boarded up on the boarded up windows
don't worry no matter how hard you board
your windows no man how many blm slogans
you put on there ain't gonna protect you
this is uh yeah again these pictures are
it's pretty obvious what's going on here
right
okay so what exactly is the political
response to all of this because
this would be a good time for all of the
political class to in unison
denounce antifa the blm writers and
looters
by name they won't do it because the
democrats are afraid of splitting their
coalition
so instead they've decided on an
alternative narrative the alternative
narrative is this is all trump's fault
but if it weren't for trump none of this
would happen now i'm old enough to
remember when their riots in ferguson
and baltimore i'm old enough to remember
when there were riots in milwaukee the
president at that time was a man named
barack obama he was the first black
president of the united states you may
recall didn't stop the riots in ferguson
or baltimore or in milwaukee it is only
that the narrative has been exacerbated
under president trump because the left
have decided that they wish to grant
more room for people to riot and loot
that is what is happening so mayor ted
wheeler the garbage mayor of portland is
a perfect case in point of this
so ted wheeler rej he sent a letter
rejecting federal help he sent that
letter on august 28th
and today is the 31st so that means that
he sent the letter
on friday here is the letter from mayor
ted wheeler remember this is before a
weekend where a man was murdered on the
streets of portland
by an antifa member allegedly quote dear
president trump
yet again you said you offered to aid
portland by sending in federal law
enforcement to our city
on behalf of the city of portland no
thanks we don't need your politics of
division and demagoguery
portlanders are on to you we have
already seen your reckless disregard for
human life in your bumbling response to
the coveted pandemic
and we know you've reached the
conclusion that images of violence or
vandalism are your only ticket to
re-election
there's no place for looting arson or
vandalism in our city there's no room
here for racist violence or those who
wish to bring their ideology of hate
into our community
those who commit criminal acts will be
apprehended and prosecuted under the law
now let me pause there for just a second
there have been running riots in the
city of portland for
three full months every single night
every night and what he's saying is i
don't want any trump supporters in my
town
because they're the bad guys right
there's no room here for racist violence
okay so apparently it's not racist
violence if you're just shot for being a
trump supporter
i love that he says those who commit
criminal acts will be apprehended and
prosecuted under the law weird because
uh there is a suspect
you may recall him he was a he was
arrested actually
apparently like a june 5th protest
carrying a gun they didn't have a
license for you remember this and then
you released him and he murdered
somebody
hmm hmm so it seems like mayor ted
wheeler actually um
is not very good at his job or he's very
good at his job his job is just not what
everybody thinks his job is which is to
keep the citizens safe
said tens of thousands of portlanders
have peacefully protested and marched
for the noble cause of fixing our broken
criminal justice system
they are part of the proud progressive
tradition of portlanders fighting for
justice from racial justice to economic
justice to environmental justice
when you sent the feds to portland last
month you made the situation far worse
really was it worse when the feds were
there or was it basically the same
except the feds were there
your offer to repeat that disaster is a
cynical attempt to stoke fear
and distract us from the real work of
our city in portland we are focused on
coming together
as a community to solve the serious
challenges we face due to systemic
racism
a global pandemic and an economic
recession notice among the list of
problems they face in portland
not the burning of the center of the
city or the complete takeover
of major thoroughfares by antifa or the
ongoing violence each and every night
the only problem here is trump and the
media by this bullcrap
hook line and synchro i mean it really
is incredible so ted wheeler then did a
press conference
he said trump has to stay the hell out
of the way trump's not going to help he
needs to stay the hell out of the way
weird because um trump has mainly stayed
the hell out of the way and your city's
been on fire for three months you stupid
jackass
here's mayor ted wheeler the worst
governor the worst mayor in america and
now
he's surpassed bill de blasio it takes a
lot to surpass bill de blasio the
groundhog murderer
he has an opportunity to uplift us and
bring us together
and help us move through this difficult
situation
in our nation's history and instead he
chooses to play petty
politics and divide us that's my
reaction so i'm going to do the work
that i need to do here in my local
community
with my local officials to take
accountability for what's happening on
our streets
and i'd appreciate that either the
president support us or you stay the
hell out of the way
this is epic levels of gaslighting epic
levels of gaslighting
that this guy completely abandoned his
city to antifa and it's trump's fault at
the federal level when trump's like hey
would you like some troops he's like no
that's stoking hatred and division we
can't have that then he went on he said
it's trump creating the hatred and
division
oh trump yeah it's all about trump by
the way if you buy this you are a rube
okay if you buy the idea that all evil
starts and ends with trump you're a rube
if you believe that riots in a major
ameri in america's major cities led
by outside antifa agitators and yes blm
rioters and looters
that that violence is a product of
president trump's cruelty
and malice and malicious evil you are a
rube and they are treating you as a
sucker okay but
they are treating as a sucker here's
mayor ted wheeler treating his sucker
it's you who have created the hate
in the division it's you who have not
found a way to say the names of black
people
killed by police officers even as people
in law enforcement have
and it's you who claimed that white
supremacists
are good people your campaign of fear
is as anti-democratic as anything you've
done to create
hate and vitriol in our beautiful
country
you've tried to divide us more than any
other figure in modern history
and now you want me to stop the violence
that you helped create trump didn't
create the violence in portland are you
insane
portland is entirely blue entirely if
you can find
i mean portland is like the scene from
the bible where abraham says to god you
know can we find 10 good people in sodom
and gomorrah
and god's like well actually no can you
find 10 republicans in the city of
portland
doesn't mean it's not a full equation
it's not like the only good people are
republicans okay the point is
there's not 10 republicans in the city
of portland the hell are you talking
about
the hell are you talking about and then
wheeler says i'll bring us back together
really how's that going for you mayor
the bringing of the people back together
this is it the people who elected this
guy you know
i've been quoting h.l bank and more and
more frequently these days the
famous columnist from the early 20th
century uh and uh as
my favorite hl man quote the american
people get what they deserve good and
hard
and uh in portland you're getting what
you deserve good and hard i mean you
voted for this this is what you get
now the work that we have to do in our
communities across this nation
in the wake of the murder of george
floyd i'm up to that challenge
and i hope the president is too and i'm
ready to reach across
any aisles i need to reach across any
political divides that i need to cross
in order to bring us back together
somebody's got to do it i'm committed to
it i know my colleagues on the portland
city are
committed to it i'd like to hear the
president of the united states
say he's all in let's bring this great
nation back together how gullible do you
have to be to believe this
how gullible trump was like i'll give
you feds he's like i'm willing to work
across the aisle except for you mr
president you're a piece of crap and i'm
not going to work with you and i'm going
to let city burning let somebody get
shot
to death in the city over the weekend
okay so trump's response all points to
trump here somebody tweeted out ted
wheeler is the useless effing idiot in
comic relief that everyone that gets
everyone killed in every disaster movie
and trump tweeted out tone down the
language but true
okay normally as you know i'm not big on
the inflammatory trump tweets
correct correct can we get to more of
this in just a second because here's
what's really happening what's really
happening is the media
and the democrats were willing to allow
this crap to go on for months on end
because they backed the underlying
agenda which is that the american system
is systemically racist
and systemically classist and evil and
all of these substructures of american
society must be torn down
this is a revolution not an evolution
you don't work inside the system you
have to work outside the system
this is the ibram candy robin d'angelo
tear down the entire system nonsense on
the basis of race
this is the bernie sanders tear down the
entire system on the basis of class
stuff
okay all of this has been bubbling under
the surface for quite a while and
democrats were allowed were willing
to allow a few a little bit of it to
spring into action
with these riots they're willing to
allow it to happen and pretend that it
wasn't happening until the point in
which the polls turned
and then the polls turned and now
they're struggling for a new narrative
because they're still not willing to
condemn it so instead
what they do is they soft condemn all
violence all over the world you know
what's really bad what's bad
sure it's like bad that there's left and
right wing violence it's bad
that there's some bad stuff happening in
the cities but also
that there's bad stuff happening in
cambodia there's bad stuff happening
everywhere guys so this is the new demo
and it's all trump's fault oh it's
trump's fault this is the new democratic
line it ain't gonna work
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because the democrats are
beginning to realize this is backfiring
on them big time and now they're
struggling and they should be struggling
because they are the ones who decided to
feed the alligator and the alligator
will eat them last
and we're gonna get to that in one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you're thinking to yourself right
now well everything seems like it is uh
insane
can i even still get life insurance i
mean we got like a cove pandemic on
we've got riots in major cities like is
now a good time to get life insurance
the answer yes now is an excellent time
to get life insurance
okay if you want to make sure your
family is taken care of and be a
responsible human being then make sure
you get life insurance and do it
the most responsible way by getting the
best policy for the best price
using policy genius right now you could
say 1500 bucks or more a year
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more those savings really do
start to add up so what exactly is
policy genius well
i'm glad you asked step one you head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price step two
you apply for that lowest price and step
three policy genius does
the rest of it like all of it they have
great service they have policies that
even allow eligible customers to skip
the in-person medical exam and do it
over the phone which is really valuable
these days you know we here at daily
wirehood using policy genius my friend
jeremy boring bought a life insurance
policy through policy genius he checked
out all the competitors policy genius
was indeed the best they gave him the
best price
they gave him the most competitive
advantage if you need life insurance
head on over to policygenius.com right
now to get started
you could say 1500 bucks or more a year
by comparing the quotes on their
marketplace policy genius when it comes
to insurance
it's nice to get it right you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so joe biden knows that he is in a
bind and the reason joe biden is in a
bind
is because he and the rest of the
democrats basically let this stuff go
for months
or patted it on the head like directly
patted it on the head
now remember democrats pretended this
stuff was not happening
remember jerry nadler less than a month
like a month ago a little bit over a
month ago this is july 27th jerry and
adler the
democratic congress person from new york
literally said that antifa violence in
portland was a myth
it does not exist this happened about a
month ago here is jerry nadler
you just about from mantiva that's
happening in portland right now that's
right
that's that's a myth that's being spread
only in washington d.c
about antifa in portland yes sir there's
there's videos everywhere online there's
fires and riots they're
throwing fireworks at a federal officers
dhs
is there look online it gets crazy
they're just traveling over to the car
and getting in and catch you later catch
you later gang
you know i mean and it's not just a
month ago it's like now okay so
joy reid who again it's amazing she ends
up with a show on msnbc msnbc
is willing to cancel anybody except
people who may very well
i mean al sharpton still has a show on
msnbc right joy reid a person who has a
bunch of old tweets that were real bad
but apparently somebody went back in
time and hacked her account
she tweeted out over the weekend over
this weekend let me repeat this for
those inventing
the idea of black lives matter riots let
me just stop there for one second
literally hannah nicole hannah jones the
de facto editor of the new york times
and 1619 project lady
she literally tweeted out that she was
happy that people were calling on the 16
19 riots
but according to go back to to go back
for a second to joy read
according to joy reid she said it's an
invented idea there are no black lives
matter right so blm doesn't riot
they march against police violence note
that those caught setting fires
assaulting and shooting people
are consistently of the right not the
left
okay um what
huh um what
i was here in l.a when they shut down
the entire damned city every night at 6
00 p.m
or 7 p.m thanks to blm rioting that was
rioting and looting
what in what is she talking about it's
not happening it's all in your
imagination poof okay so they have a
couple of narratives here
one blm doesn't riot two antifa doesn't
exist three if they do exist it's donald
trump's fault
four the real violent offenders here are
the white nationalists
okay this is crazy towns crazy they
think you're a that's what they
think
there's no other way to explain this
garbage they think you are completely
stupid they think you're a vegetable
that's what they think chris chaliza
ratio bain as we tend to call him on
twitter because he's constantly getting
ratio he's incredible at it
chris chaliza from cnn tweeted this out
he tweeted
trump's efforts to label what is
happening in major cities as riots
speaks at least somewhat to his
desperation politically speaking at the
moment
now all credit to the cnn editor who
apparently also hates chris chaliza and
wanted to troll the living hell out of
him because the picture
is of people standing in front of a
burning building
there are no riots it's just trump keeps
labeling them riots
but really it's just peaceful protests
at which a bunch of stuff gets burned
and people lose their life savings
and in which some 30 people have died i
mean sure
other than that there are no riots at
all poof
poof okay and then these same media
remember never forget that these same
media members of the democratic party
forwarded this stuff they did okay the
washington post
less than a month ago in the second week
of august published a glowing photo
essay
featuring antifa protesters in portland
okay they literally published pictures
of how antifa
looters and rioters and criminals dress
the piece this is the federalist
reporting authored by post protest
reporter marissa lang prominently
highlights testimony from several
portland activists
sharing their one-sided experiences
painting police as violent agents of an
oppressive state
with no mention of the word riot
according to lang protesters merely
directed their anger at the federal
courthouse
but here's the thing everybody looked
great
the post photo essay attempted to
capture glory of the self-righteous
organizers terrorizing the city
by weaving in professional photos of the
story subjects donning their riot gear
as if it were a maxim photo shoot
it was really really nice and they
showed all the kind of gear that they
got together and how they got dressed up
the media soft pedaled antifa for a long
time here
like for a really long time how much did
they soft pedal antifa
kamala harris literally tweeted out in
the middle of the riots in minneapolis
kamala harris tweeted out a website so
you could donate to free people
who were arrested for writing and
looting this is june 1st quote kamala
harris the now vice presidential
candidate quote
if you're able to chip in now to the
minnesota freedom fund to help post bail
for those protesting on the ground in
minnesota
so she wanted to bail out rioters and
looters okay so
don't fall for this nonsense by the way
13 members of biden's staff directly
contributed to this as well
and this was reported at the time may
30th
reuters campaign staff for democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
are advertising their donations to a
group that pays bail fees in minneapolis
after the city's police jailed people
protesting the killing of a black man by
a white police officer no they jailed
people who were rioting and looting
at least 13 biden campaign staff members
posted on twitter on friday and saturday
that they made donations to the
minnesota freedom fund which opposes the
practice of cash bail
the group uses donations to pay bail
fees in minneapolis
biden campaign spokesman andrew bates
said in a statement to reuters the
former vp opposes cash bail as quote a
modern-day debtor's prison
but the campaign declined to answer
questions on whether the donations were
coordinated within the campaign
bates instead pointed to biden's
comments that protesters have the right
to be angry but that more violence won't
solve justice problems ah there's that
soft
joe biden there there's that unity that
we've been looking for okay so
and again the media have been pushing
this stuff nonstop nicole hannah jones i
mentioned
earlier the the de facto editor of the
new york times she tweeted this out over
the weekend
quote so one you don't get to tell
people how they should respond to their
own oppression
um okay so there are a few assumptions
baked into that cake which is that if
you're rioting and looting you're
responding to oppression
rather than being a terrible human being
and that's that's the part of this tweet
that's truly offensive
and she said two please please help me
understand how black people who protest
peacefully are supposed to control and
take responsibility for the tiny fringe
of people
who decide to loot and burn things okay
weird because um
nicole hannah jones literally blames the
entire police department and by the way
right-wing protests for anything bad
that happens
involving those groups so yes nicole
hannah jones the wisest and greatest
among us
so they've been saw peddling this stuff
for a long time and this is the new
narrative
so the narrative is that it's anybody's
fault but antifa it's anybody's fault
but blm
adam schiff leads the way so adam schiff
who again i guess he still has that
bereft pup tent outside the cnn
headquarters right he's on cnn
more than dana bash nintendo bash is a
network anchor say adam schiff
the the ridiculous stupid congress
person from los angeles
i believe he may be my congress person
actually uh who who specifically
who specifically suggested for several
years that there was forthcoming
evidence that trump was a russian
cat's bar now he is saying that actually
maybe it's the russians behind this
maybe it's the russians guys it can't be
nt4 blm after all it's trump's fault and
it's the russians fault why it's almost
as though he has a preset narrative
here's adam schiff
the russians four years ago dana
exploited black lives matter they
set up their own false flags online uh
to try to divide people along racial
lines
are they doing and we have to uh they
are
once again doing their best in social
media in their overt media
and other means to grow these divisions
again
the president is willfully fanning the
flames of this
violence he will stoke it through his
social media
where he can because he believes the
violence helps him
this is the greatest form of gaslighting
i've ever seen he's offered federal
troops to every major american city to
violence and the democrats are out there
like oh it's the russians and trump
is it unbelievable again if you fall for
this you're a if you fall for this
you're a stupid human being
you have less than three brain cells to
rub together if you fall for this
this is extortion by the democrats pure
and simple and then gaslighting
following the extortion
if biden gets elected it'll all go away
but also it's not our fault we have no
control it's trump's fault and also the
group is doing it mostly white
nationalists the reason
i point this out is joe i mean this is
such pathetic stuff
so joe biden has now put out a couple of
statements
on this joe biden has put out a couple
of statements
when it came to this particular thing
he suggested that number one he
conflates the the protesters and the
writers and looters which is typical
democratic double speak
right he says that trump wanted to stick
feds on protesters right so he's just
denying that the people who are actually
doing this sort of stuff are rioters and
looters here was biden over the weekend
by standing and recommending that you
should be deployed to quote
dominate your fellow citizens for
exercising the rights to peacefully
protest
and threatening if governors didn't do
something
the president would okay no he's
specifically talking about writers and
losers so biden's a damned liar on this
okay so
biden has now released we have a couple
of statements from joe biden
quote now remember the bad guy was
donald trump in charlottesville because
he said many sides many sides here is
the statement from joe biden quote
the deadly violence we saw overnight in
portland is unacceptable shooting in the
streets of a great american city is
unacceptable
i condemn this violence unequivocally i
condemn violence of every kind by anyone
whether on the left or the right
and i challenge donald trump to do the
same it does not matter if you find the
political views of your opponents
abhorrent
any loss of life is a tragedy that today
there is another family grieving in
america and joe and i offer our deepest
condolences
we must not become a country at war with
ourselves a country that accepts the
killing of fellow americans who do not
agree with you
a country that vows vengeance toward one
another but that is the america that
donald trump wants us to be
the america he believes we are so it's
trump's fault you'll notice
is there a mention of antifa no is there
a mention there of black lives matter no
he continues as a country we must
condemn the incitement of hate and
resentment that leads this deadly clash
it is not a peaceful protest when you go
out spoiling for a fight
oh how interesting it's not a peaceful
protest when you've got spoiling for a
fight says
we showed video on this um on this very
show today of a black lives matter
activist literally calling for the
murder of police officers in the burning
down of the white house
is that a peaceful protest joe biden i
don't hear you saying anything about it
seems like you're being kind of
deliberately vague here
what does president trump think will
happen when he continues to insist on
fanning the flames
of hatred and division in our society
and using the politics of fear to whip
up his supporters
what the reason people are fearful is
because the cities are on
damned fire and they're on fire because
democrats have done nothing these are
all democratic cities
every single one of them joe biden's
vague mushmouth statements that he can
barely get out of his face
about how he doesn't like violence on
any side on many sides on many sides if
on many sides was bad for donald trump
it ain't any better for joe biden
a ridiculous hypocrite he says he may
think that warner streets again he's not
blaming trump right there's not a
mention of antifa not a mention of blm
the sources of this
not one mention but donald trump comes
up
several times in this statement he may
think that war in our streets is good
for his re-election chances but that is
not presidential leadership or even
basic human compassion again he has
offered federal forces to every one of
these mayors who have all turned him
down
where is joe biden on this the answer is
nowhere he says the job of a president
is to lower the temperature
to bring people who disagree with one
another together to make life better for
all americans the temperature in the
country is too high because of donald
trump
he's that was one of biden's statements
then there's another one of joe biden's
statements
okay so this one is even worse so joe
biden won't go to kenosha the reason he
won't go to kenosha is because he
understands what that would look like
right so this is the big story over the
weekend is that joe biden in fact will
not go to kenosha wisconsin
instead he's heading over to
pennsylvania so according to politico
joe biden will travel to western
pennsylvania on monday to give remarks
focused on how president donald trump
has made america less safe
forgoing the chance to deliver that
message in wisconsin where the president
is planning a tuesday visit
biden faced mounting pressure to visit
the battleground state amid violence
after a police shooting in kenosha
his decision to instead speak from
pennsylvania is designed to put some
space
between the violence and the former vp
as he continues to argue that unrest
is an outgrowth of the president's
rhetoric that inflames racial tension
biden's speech monday will focus on how
trump continues to fan the flames of
division and encourage chaos
and so the real reason he's not going to
kenosha biden is because he's a coward
it's because joe biden would show up in
kenosha there'd be a backdrop of a burn
city
and he'd be forced to argue that somehow
this was trump's fault
in an area where the rioters are all blm
and antifa
you'd have to argue that somehow this
was trump that's not a good look when
the area behind you has been burned out
by people who back joe biden every one
of those people is a joe biden voter the
people who are burning down buildings
the people who are rioting and looting
are joe biden voters
so biden knew that which is why he's not
showing up in kenosha so naturally he
has to have
the democrats play cleanup for him in
wisconsin
which means that the governor of
wisconsin tony evers
sent a letter to president trump asking
him
to not go to kenosha so let me get this
straight it's trump's fault because he
won't calm tensions
also we don't want your federal troops
also don't come to kenosha seriously
this is their this is their case
it's trump's fault that all this is
happening despite the fact he offered
500 additional national guardsmen before
kenosha went completely crazy and the
shootings occurred
despite the fact that he routinely
offers troops to portland
nothing but if trump shows up it's bad
and if trump tries to send troops that's
bad
trump is the bad man right obviously
obviously it's trump's fault tony evers
this ridiculous
stupid governor of wisconsin who's
responsible for this stuff again he's
the governor of a state you have one job
protect the life liberty and property of
your citizens that's it that is your
sole job
and he's not doing it tony ever sent
this letter to president trump because
again it's all about trump for democrats
it is not about protecting the
protecting the citizenry it is not about
protecting the citizenry
here is the letter tony ever sent to
trump because trump said he's going to
come speak in kenosha
dear president trump i understand
yesterday you indicated you would be
visiting kenosha and according to pool
reports last night you intend to visit
kenosha this tuesday
i write today to respectfully ask you to
reconsider these past few months from
managing a pandemic to facing entrenched
racial disparities and inequities our
state
like so many others has faced
unimaginable challenges but this past
week has been particularly difficult
kenosha and communities across wisconsin
are enduring extraordinary grief
grappling with a black man being shot
seven times and the loss of two
additional lives on tuesday night at the
hands of an out-of-state armed militant
okay well
you're missing a few facts there tony
evers you might be missing the fact
that the man who was shot and the black
man who was shot seven times
was actively resisting arrest there was
an open warrant for both domestic abuse
and sexual assault
that the police tried to subdue him he
refused to be subdued they tased him
twice that failed he walked around the
other side of the car
he reached into the car and on the floor
boards of the driver's side was a knife
that's a little bit relevant and the at
the the shootings at the quote unquote
hands of an out-of-state armed militant
kyle rittenberg kyle rittenberg whatever
the guy's name is
rittenhouse kyle rittenhouse should not
have been there
okay i said that myself he's not a
trained person he shouldn't have been
there
the shootings are pretty obviously
self-defense he was being assaulted at
the time somebody fired a shot before he
even fired the first shot and then
somebody tried to beat the hell out of
him another guy approached him with a
pistol
okay so just skipping all the facts
right here because obviously the
narrative is that
the real violence is not what was
happening in kenosha before kyle
rittenhouse even showed up
the real violence was apparently the
cops
and the out-of-state armed guy when i
visited kenosha last week what i saw was
a community working to deal with the
trauma and pain of these events and
extreme laws this again
the governor of wisconsin they are
exhausted and heartbroken with the
division that has ripped apart their
community but they are also working to
rebuild
together and support each other in the
face of adversity i along with other
community leaders who have reached out
are concerned about what your presence
will mean for kenosha and our state
i am concerned your presence will only
hinder our healing i am concerned your
presidents will only delay our work
to overcome division and move forward
together ah yeah it's trump that's the
problem in kenosha got it
it is our job as elected officials to
lead by example and be a calming present
now is not the time
for divisiveness well that would be the
time for you to have called federal
troops in weeks ago
now is not the time for elected
officials to ignore armed militias
and out of state instigators who want to
contribute to our english ignore armed
militants
weird ignoring our militants so i have
some stats by the way on um who was just
arrested in kenosha
okay here are the stats on who was
arrested in kenosha 175 people arrested
last week
102 have home addresses outside kenosha
across 44 different cities 69 arrested
for violating curfew
34 for curfew plus other charges like
burglary drugs and weapons and over 20
firearms seized
so who's ignoring the outside agitators
actually it seems like
it's governor tony evers so of course
it's trump's fault
he says i urge you to revisit your
decision to visit kenosha on tuesday
thanks for your time and for
consideration of this request again it's
all trump's fault so
biden won't go to kenosha because it
would be humiliating for him it would
look ridiculous
and so now you got the governor saying
trump can't come to kenosha because
that would be embarrassing for democrats
really is what they're saying and then
wisconsin lieutenant governor went on
national tv said the same thing
trump shouldn't show up because really
this is kind of trump's fault isn't it
you look at the incendiary remarks that
the president has made
they centered an entire convention
around creating more animosity and
creating more division around what's
going on in kenosha
so i don't know how given any of the
previous statements that the president
made that he intends to come here to be
helpful
and we absolutely don't need that right
now no we need is apparently
a complete lack of law enforcement and
you ripping on the cops daily this is
the same lieutenant governor who just
days ago suggested no investigation is
necessary in the jacob blake case
to conclude that this is just another
incident of a black man being
unjustifiably shot
yeah well that's that's more of what we
need that's clearly okay so all of this
leads to what joe biden is actually
going to say today so
he is speaking in pittsburgh
pennsylvania and here is his speech
prepared for delivery you ready for this
remember again i'm going to keep coming
back to it because it is worthy of note
the single the the single moment that
supposedly initiated the biden campaign
was the evil of donald trump at
charlottesville for not labeling the
alt-right and the white supremacist at
the outs from the outset is the bad guys
right
many sides many sides here is joe biden
on the riots and the looting and the
murder here is joe biden you ready
this president long ago forfeited any
moral leadership in this country
he can't stop the violence because for
years he has fomented it
he may believe mouthing the words law
and order makes him strong but his
failure to call on his own supporters to
stop acting as an armed militia in this
country
shows you how weak he is oh it's the
militias
for months we've been watching the
cities burned but it's the militias who
are just arriving in the last five
minutes are the problem
oh well this is galaxy brand stuff
does anyone believe there will be less
violence in america if donald trump is
reelected you're saying the quiet part
out loud now joe
which is that you're basically pledging
that the violence won't end until trump
is out of office
he says economic devastation unwarranted
police violence
emboldened white nationalists a
reckoning on race okay look at
look at the gas lighting there look at
that look at the gas lighting there
economic devastation the economic
devastation has been wrought
largely by democratic governors
completely shutting down their states
with no end insight in the middle of the
coven pandemic
unwarranted police violence okay again
has he made the case
that the police violence in kenosha was
unwarranted no
is he bothered no how about richard
brookson atlanta no
how about brianna taylor has he has he
mentioned the illegality there
it may be a tragedy but it was not
illegal like
the real problem though is unwarranted
police files you've seen riot we we have
seen
rioting for months on end in major
cities
and we've got unwarranted police
violence labels here emboldened white
nationalists oh that's
because what we're watching in the
cities is white nationalists not black
lives matter
writers and looters and and agitators
trying to
beat up rand paul and shouting at people
coming out of the white house and what
do we get a reckoning on race ah
it's a reckoning guys oh well the real
the these are there's good
again remember this isn't even on many
sides on many sides he's explicitly
saying one side is good and one side is
bad and the people who are doing the
rioting and looting are the good guys
and everybody else is just agitating
them that is the big problem here
that is incredible stuff from joe biden
and this is the guy calming the tensions
this is the guy calling the tensions not
one member of the media not
one we'll have the balls to ask joe
biden to condemn by name antifa or blm
riders and looters
not one instead they'll just let him get
away with this mealy mouth bull
they'll just let him get away with it
this mealy mouth nonsense where he just
says things like
well you know what this really is it's
the white nationalist militias and it's
really about trump and it's really about
like everybody on all sides
they'll let him get away with it because
they agree with the agenda how do i know
they agree with the agenda because they
started repeating it over the weekend so
chuck todd
literally went on tv over the weekend
and asked mark meadows the chief of
staff to president trump
isn't this donald trump's america so
just to get this straight
just to get this straight when andrew
cuomo was being hailed as a hero as a
hero it's andrew cuomo's new york
and when mayor ted wheeler is turning
down federal help it's mayor ted
wheeler's heroism against donald trump
but when violence occurs in these cities
then it's donald trump's america
here's chuck todd suggesting this is all
donald trump's america
weird because these are all democratic
cities who hate donald trump here's
chuck todd repeating the narrative
repeat and believe everyone
this is in donald trump's america um how
much responsibility should voters be
giving the president
for his inability um to
to to keep the streets safe
is there parts of the country that the
president doesn't govern
i mean is the president only in charge
of what
of just where places where he has
supporters does the president not
believe he has responsibility
of governing and leading the entire
country he's tried he offered federal
help and then you called him a fascist
you and the media called him a fascist
you can't have it both ways that's not
how this works
you don't get to say trump has to handle
this and then trump says okay you want
the troops hear the troops you're like
no you don't want the troops you're a
fascist
but it's your fault okay and then it was
dana bash too isn't trump inflaming the
tensions he just keeps inflaming the
tensions he's inflaming the tensions you
in the media have repeated for months
there is no rioting there is no looting
it's magically not occurring it's all in
your imagination these are mostly
peaceful protests
cnn ran a chiron last week fiery but
mostly peaceful protests
fiery but mostly peaceful protests chris
chaliza your idiot
media analyst put out a statement on
twitter yesterday
saying that these are not riots and that
trump is making up the riots
but it's the republicans emboldening
these people i have a question
who in blm is listening to ron johnson
the
senator from wisconsin who from blm is
like well you know so now that ron
johnson said something i guess i'm going
to go burn some stuff down
like what in the world but the media are
going to repeat this because again
repeat and believe
i want to talk about what happened in
portland we saw someone
get killed overnight amid clashes there
and
the president has been tweeting and
retweeting
before dawn this morning he called for
the mayor of portland to resign and be
arrested he painted protesters as thugs
and cities in chaos you are the chairman
as i mentioned of the senate homeland
security committee
are you comfortable with the president
appearing to inflame
tensions instead of what we normally see
from presidents which is trying to calm
them down
riders and looters are thugs they are
now there's a strain on the left that
actually that actually
touts this stuff like openly touted over
the weekend there's an article from npr
it was called one author's argument in
defense of looting there's an actual
book by a writer named vicki osterweil
called
in defense of looting and vicki ostrow
said quote when i used the word looting
i mean this was npr right you're
publicly funded npr when i use the word
looting i mean the mass expropriation of
property mass shoplifting
shoplifting during a moment of upheaval
or riot that's the thing i'm defending
i'm not defending any situation in which
property is stolen by force
that's literally property being stolen
by force if you break into a walmart and
steal stuff
that doesn't make it not robbery it's
not a home invasion either says vicky
osterweil it's about a certain kind of
action that's taken during protests and
riots
looting is a highly racialized word from
its very inception it's taken from the
hindi lute which means goods or spoils
so apparently even you say looting now
you're a racist
rioting generally refers to any moments
of mass unrest or upheaval
riots are a space in which a massive
people has produced a situation in which
the general laws that govern society
no longer function and people can act in
different ways in the street and in
public
i'd say that rioting is a broader
category says vicky ostrow interviewed
by npr over the weekend
in which looting appears as a tactic
often looting is more common among
movements that are coming from below
it tends to be an attack on a business a
commercial space maybe a government
building
taking those things that otherwise would
be commodified and controlled and
sharing them for free
it's good it's good now you'll note
something
the people who are constantly saying
this stuff is good making excuses for it
are either radicals
like the blm organization or they are
upper-class white people who do not give
a damn about the quality of life of
people who are more impoverished than
they are
largely minority who are desperately
aching for some level of law and order
and protection of private property and
life in their community
so vicky asteroids asked that somebody
asked during recent riots the sentiments
i heard was that looters in cities like
minneapolis were hurting their own cause
by destroying small businesses in their
own neighborhoods
stores owned by immigrants and people of
color what would you say to people who
make that argument
people who made that argument from
minneapolis as victor vicki osweil
weren't suddenly celebrating the looters
in chicago who drove down to the richest
part of chicago the magnificent mile
and attack places like tesla and gucci
because it's not really about that
it's a convenient way of positioning
yourself as though you are sympathetic
but looters and rioters don't attack
private homes they don't attack
community centers
in minneapolis there was a small
independent bookstore that was untouched
all the blocks around it were basically
looted or even leveled burned down
and that store just remained untouched
through weeks of rioting you want to
know why the bookstore didn't get burned
down because nobody's stealing books
they're stealing tvs if you're a looter
you're gonna go right to the used
bookstore
you're gonna pick up a first edition of
like
a place in the sun like what what what
are you talking about
to say you're attacking your own
community is to say to writers you don't
know what you're doing but i disagree i
think people know
amazing okay so this has been going on
on a very fairly low level and
tudded on a high level by the democrats
for literally years now being promoted
on npr openly there's an article in 2014
at time magazine called in defense of
violent protests there's an article in
the nation
that came out i believe 2016. titled in
defense of destroying property
they don't care okay this has been
actively fomented and now the the line
the corrective line is well it's all
trump's fault maybe it's the russians
maybe it's the white supremacists no the
answer is you want to tut-tut and
poo-poo the rioting
and the looting in america's major
cities because you agree with the cause
so if you agree with the cause it's just
a question of means not a question of
ends and the last thing you want to do
is alienate people
who may vote for joe biden because
they're members of blm or sympathetic to
antifa
and that's repulsive and disgusting and
anybody who fails to call this out or
fall
for joe biden's garbage statements about
how this is really
about widespread american discontent or
it's about trump or it's really about
white supremacists
it's because it's because you want to be
a fool it's because you want to be
fooled you either want to be fooled
because you're a soft liberal who hates
trump and so you want biden elected and
so you're willing to overlook all of
this stuff
or because you're a hard leftist who
actually sort of agrees with antifa and
blm
and all evil can be wrapped up in a
trump flag
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
including
some coveted content we didn't get to
because it's actually fairly important
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
riotous democrats murder another
conservative in the street leftists try
to flip the script
and a movie star makes a quick million
in do-it-yourself porn
check it out on the michael knowles show